これはすごいストーリーとして面白いストーリーです
で これストーリーを言うと
この芸の大事な尊い意味が消えちゃいますからね
なんで仏陀がそういう
そんなことをしたのかと私はわかりませんだけどね
あの三十三天の天国にもう
三十三天っていうのはこの天界の二番目なんですね
下から ある天女たちがいっぱいいて
また男性の神もいて 男性の神の奥さんたちですね
みんなこの天国でずいぶん楽しく遊んでいるんです
そこで天国でもうすごい公園がありまして
いっぱい花が咲いていて
天国の話だからね で みんな花を摘んで
いろいろこの自分の旦那をいろいろ美しく飾るみたいですね
それで遊んでいる ある女性が自分もなんかいろいろ花を取っている間で
すぐ亡くなったんです
この花でこうやって飾ってやろうと思ってね
旦那を で やっているだけでもう亡くなったんですね
天国では死体とか何もないんだからね
そのままぽっと消えるだけで
肉体はないんだからね
彼女はそのまま天界で消えちゃったんです
消えて もうインドで人間の世界
どこかで女の人のお腹の中に生まれたんです
そこで生まれて で 突然人間になったんだからね
自分の過去をすぐ思い出しちゃったんです
だから人間の社会に自覚が出てくると
すぐ過去を思い出せますよ
結構人間にありますよ
だからこの そんな珍しいことでもないんです
もうそっちはあることでね
当然子供は人間に自覚した
自覚した時点でもう思い出したりする
で なんとか喋れるようになってる
もう喋ったりもしますけどね
まあこれはもう恐ろしい考えていけないことだから
まあもう文化的には潰しちゃうんですね
もうヨーロッパでも日本でも
そういうことはもうすぐ潰す
子供をバカにする あなたおかしいとかね
言って恥をかけられるんだから
それで能力まで潰してしまい
潰られてしまいます 輪廻転生というのは当たり前のことで
別に珍しく何でもないって思うところでは
別に気にしない そうかということでも終わっちゃうんです
あんまり派手にもう人間のことを言うと
これは調べられるぞと
私はあそこであそこで生まれていたんだよとかなんとか言うと
そのデータを持って そういうところでそういう人がいたしんだのかとかね
調べたりして そういうのはちょっとずつテキストを作ったりはします
証拠として 人間 意外なところだったら
これはもうどうにもならん
で この人はやっぱり自分がもうこちらじゃなくて
もうよって三十三手にいたんではないかと
と自分の旦那のことを思い出しちゃって
ああ もったいないことをしちゃったと
とにかくそちらに行きたいんだと
自分がもう彼の奥さんですと
いうことで天国に帰りたい
帰りたいと それしか頭にないんですね
それで大きくなって もうずっともう布施をするはあらゆることをするんですね
小さい時から 十六歳になったところで
もう一人前になって はぁ
みんなに言う 私は過去生でね
こういう神のところにいたんだと
私の旦那はその人やと
いうことで みんなあだ名まで作ったんですね
彼女に だからまあ一生懸命善行為を徳を積む
でお坊さんたちにあらゆるお布施をする
まああらゆる色 何か考えてはお布施をする
でお世話もする で 食事をやら
そこは綺麗に掃除したり
水を汲んであげたり 何から何までやる
そうすると他の人々も自分たちの当番で食事を持っていくことになっていたっても
彼女に頼むんで ではお願いしますから用意しておいてくださいとかね
彼女はすごい喜んで協力したりするってこと
そこで結婚して子供を産むんですよ
子供をどんどん 4人産むんですね
で 年にもなって ちゃんと道徳戒律を守って
病気になって死ぬんです
死んだら一生彼女はこの元の旦那のことしか考えたことはないんだからね
それだけ期待してずっと善行為一色で生きていたんですね
だから亡くなったら すぐ天国で同じところに生まれ変わったんです
生まれ変わった旦那 君ちょっと見かけなかったんですけど
どこ行ったのかと まだ遊んでいるんですよ
公園で話すので みんなでワイワイと遊んでると
ちょこっとある女性が消えちゃって
女性が消えてしまっちゃって
亡くなって まだいるんですね
どこ行ったの？と 見えなかったんだよと
そしたら彼女は あ 私は死にましたよと
それでまた生まれ変われたんだと言って
自分のエピソードを全部言ったそうです
これぐらいの大変なことをやっていたんだ
生まれて大きくなって
結婚もして 子供 4人も産んで
年も取って もう必死でお布施をして
もうあれこれともうやりたいこと
ボランティア 何でもやって
年取って死んで生まれたんだよと
あれ 人間の世界ってそんなに短いんですかと
寿命はと いう話なんです
そこで神々は人間っていうのはほんの瞬間しか寿命ないのに
この連中何やってるんですかと
だから天国の次元で考えちゃったんで
バカバカらしいことよくやってるんだと
ほんのあっという間の寿命だから
もうさっさと良いことをしなきゃあかんのに
すごいバカに見えたみたいですね
神々に人間のこと だから自分の奥さんがこういう話をしたんだから
ほんとそういう一つ人間に生まれて
年も取って死んで変わって天国に戻ったでしょ
我々にとってはほんのちょっとの話ですよと
だから人間でもちょっと女性がちょっとお寺に行って帰ったぐらいの時間なんですよ
その間では見えないんですけど
別にすごい時間って ないでしょうに
ほんのそれぐらいの寿命ですかと
人間のそれぐらいの寿命でよくも怠って生活するんだと
戦争するわ 喧嘩するわ
憎しみ合うわ 土地に争うわ
まあ競争するわ もうキリがないんだから
そこで年の寿命の人年たった 年なのに
人間というのはここまで怠って
ここまで ここまで愚かな生き方をするんだったら
生命には苦しみをなくすということはありえないでしょうと
ということで その旦那の神さんが
神が大変この緊張感という
もうじっとしていられないんだったという
生まれてきたんですね
三位一体というもの 自分たちの天国では一日百年ぐらいですね
だからまあ天国ではたった一日の間なんですね
こちらは百年ですと 天国では三十三天で百年です
上に行けばもっと長いんです
三十三天の寿命は ビッバン ワッサ サハッサン アユッパ マナ千年ですね
千年といえば人間 人間の千年じゃないんです
人間の生命は十日だけですからね
ではないんです 向こうの年月で千年です
それも三十日は 一ヶ月で
十二月は一年で それで千年ですからね
まあそんな風なストーリーで
まあダイスタ だからそれに合わせているでしょうね
だから花が取っている間でもう人死ぬということだね
あんまり合わないね お釈迦様の時とは
そのストーリーは で まあ道徳的に言えば
まあもう天界の次元から考えても
人間の命っていうのはちっぽけな短いものだから
無駄にするなよというね
この機会は この徳を積む機会っていうのは人間にだ
ほとんど人間にはあるんですよ
他の生命にはなかなかできない
例えば天国の天界の神々が徳を積まなくちゃと思ったってもできないんだから
いいことをしなくちゃいけないんだとか思ったってもね
それはできないんです
だからそこでもう千年かける百はいくらでしたっけ？千年十万
だから我々の寿命は十万年だよとかね
って思ったってもね 何のいいこともできない
だから人間になったらまあ苦しいんだけど
人間の生き方はね 天国みたいな決して楽ではありません
何でも自分でやらなくちゃいけない世界なんです
で ほぼ動物とは同じことで
動物の場合はさらに苦しいだけで
もうやっと餌見つかるんであって
それもしっかり三食食べるぞっていうことはありえない
人間には努力することで
ちゃんと三食ぐらいは何とかもう食べられるようにすることはできるし
もうない人には他の人々にあげたりもするし
その時点では楽なんですけど
動物の世界では餌取れないんだったら
他の動物が餌を運んであげるぞってことはこれありえないでしょうしね
自分でやらなくちゃいけない
そういう微妙に動物の世界よりはちょっと微妙に楽かもしれませんだけど
でも我々は何でも自分でやらなくちゃいけない生命体なんですね
なのにそれを忘れちゃうんですね
みんなやってくれると思っている
もう経済状況が悪いんだから
もう世界が変わって良くしてくれると待っているとかね
不景気はまあそのうちなくなるでしょうと
不景気をなくすためには努力しなくちゃあかんですけど
しない そこがおかしいんですよ
必死であらゆる努力をしないと
日本だけでしょ いまだにバブル崩壊してからその落ちた穴からいまだに立ち上がってないの
言いながら世界一の経済学者がいる国やと自慢もするんですよ
シンガポールに対して
マレーシアに対して あの two つの国もかなりショック受けちゃったんですよ
日本よりもすごいショック受けたんです
バブルで でも今は全然忘れているんです
あったっていうことを
すぐたちまち行動したんです
ピシピシと だからやっぱり自分でやらないと
アメリカは大きな皿を持って幸福をね
経済成長を持ってくると思ったらね
これはちょっと違うんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
だから人間の生き方っていうのは
我々何だかんでも自分でやらなくちゃいけない
これも覚えた方がいいんです
もう遅いんですけど 皆様の場合はね
意味もないし 私はいくら説法したっても全部外れ
で もう年は取ってるんだから
仏教は生き生きとしてる人間に語るものですから
まあしょうがないんですけど
だからとにかく小さいうちに聞いてもらわないと
で そういう話は残るのはとにかくもう遅くないんだから心清らかにしなさいという話ですけどね
皆様に適用できるのは
一応人間の生き方というのは何でも自分でやらなくちゃいけない世界なんです
だから甘えては決していけないし
自分のことは何だかんでも自分でやると
やっぱりそういうことでなきゃ大変なんですよ
家内はいつでも料理作ってくれるんだぞと言って
もう食うだけの人生だったら
もし死んじゃったらどうするのか
もう自分一人で生きていられなくなるでしょうに
女性はそう思ってないんだからね
旦那が全部お金持ってくるんだから
完全に頼りそうとは思ってなくて
全部いっぱいへそくりするんだからね
もう死んじゃったっても
へっちゃらってことはありますけどね
やっぱりそれでもすごい精神的にはショックを受けちゃって
寂しくて いろいろということでね
とにかくやっぱり自分のことは自分でやらなくちゃいけない苦しい人生なんです
それはもうしょうがないんです
業はそういう風に働くもので
憎しみもあるし 嫉妬もあるし
競争心もあるし 怒りもあるし
欲もあるし そういうものはごちゃごちゃあるんだからこそ
そこら辺は是非業管理できますよ
自然の法則で怒る環境にいるんです
奪い合わなくちゃいけない環境にいるんです
そこで奪い合うことはしないと
怒る環境にいるのにも関わらず
怒らないようにすると
嫉妬する環境にいるにも関わらず嫉妬しないことにするということで
道徳をできる環境ができているんです
善行できる環境でもあります
天界ではないんです 嫉妬なんかはないんです
というか そういう環境じゃないんです
自分の業でできている体だから
自分の業に関わるものしか見えませんよ
だから隣の神は私よりは優れているんだとか
そういうふうには思えないんです
自分の業のエネルギーに関わる環境はいっぱい見える
それ以外は知らない だから嫉妬するとか
憎しむとか そこはあんまりないんですね
楽しくいる で そういう嫉妬する神もいるみたいですけど
あの そこでこの嫉妬が起きたら
その時点で死んでしまうんだそうです
業がパシッと弾けちゃうんです
で 怒りが生まれたその時点でもう自分の寿命はもう弾けちゃうんです
どうせもう心でできている体だから
もうすごい脆い神の体っていうのは
だからずっと心で支えてあげないとあかんですよ
人間の場合はものすごい重い肉体を持ってるんだからね
心がたとえ悪くても いきなり体も悪くなるということはないんです
でもあるんですよ 長い時間悪いくらい心でいると
肉体にも結果影響を与えます
時間かかるんですね それでも
今日怒って今日心臓発作死するんだったら誰も怒りはしません
今日ずっと怒っちゃうと
もう三年経ったところでがんになるんだから
もう忘れてるんですね
だから人間は思いをすごい思い
もう苦しい肉体を持ってるんだから
嫉妬しただけで死んだりもしないし
憎しだけでもそれで体壊れることはないんですけど
天界ではこれは危ないんですね
心だけ支えですからね
だからそちらではそれはありがたい話でもないんですよ
逆にそちらでも寿命は無常で寿命ではなくて
命は無常であって危ないということはそのまま
それ知ってる人々は瞑想して
天国はもうちょっと徳積んだって行くんだからね
天国は嫌やと梵天に行きますよと
で 梵天に行くんですけど
そちらに行ったらもう決まってる
寿命は完成して亡くなるんです
そちらは一定の心の波動でいますから
心の波がないんですね
でも寿命が終わったら亡くなりますし
だから私が言いたいのは
天界は楽しいところやと
なんとかとかありがたいところではなくて
仏教というのは全然徳を積めない環境ですと
だから人間は一番いいんだけど
悪いことに寿命は短い
これで人間が得をすることではなくて
何を食べるか どこでそれだけに一生かかっちゃうんですね
皆様はすごいことを文化的なことをやってるとか言っても
全て金に関わっているものですよ
金のためにやってますよ
何だかんだ だから全部引き算全部引いて最後に何が残ったかというと
私は一生死ぬまで食い物を探していたんだよという答えになるんですよ
これからきちんと計算してみて下さい
人生を きちんと人生計算してみれば
もう年取ってもくたびれるまで何やってきたのか
来たんでしょうかというと
私はすごい充実した仕事をしたんだと言ったっても
結局それはもう餌探しでしょうに
立派なもう自慢で自慢できる家作ったんだよと
あるいは設計士を 私は色んなところで面白い
もう建物いっぱい設計したんだよと
あの建物は私の設計 あの建物は私設計自慢できます
あなたは何やったの？あなたは食い物探しただけでしょうと
設計図を描きながら だから正しい計算すると我々は一生やってるのはそればっかりなんですよ
それで短い人生終わっちゃうと
いつ徳を積むのかと だから仏教から見れば
こんなどんな立派な仕事でも全然しゃれにも自慢にもならない
私は総理になってたとか
だから何よと それはあなたそれで食ってるんでしょうと
ちょっと自慢したいんだから
私は人生成功したんだよと
死ぬまでの話でしょうに
たとえ総理になったっても
もうどうったことはないんですよ
その餌探すこと以外に何かやっているのかと
だから簡単な理解しやすいことは寄付をしたり
布施をしたりする で 人に何か
苦しんでる人に何か差し上げるっていうことは
その人から見返り考えてないでしょ
だから商売じゃないんですね
それが自分が餌探しの行為じゃないんです
社長に もうお正月でいっぱい高い
何でしたっけ あれは 何て言いますか
お歳暮を持って行ったっても
それがお布施ではなくて
明らかに商売ですね 自分の仕事を安定するために
結局食い物探しっていう次元からはもう外れてないんです
それで そこら辺にいるホームレスの人を見つけて
せっかくお正月だからあなたも
何それっていうんですか？正月の料理は
おせち おせち料理  おせち
君もおせち料理食べなさいよと言って
もう安いものもありますからね
四千 三千円でも買えるね
だから三千円のおせち
じゃあこれ食べてください
お正月でしょ？みんな楽しまなくちゃいけないんだというと
それがプラスアルファの行為なんですよ
すぐ結果出ますよ 自分にはほんまに
本当にお正月っていう気分にその時なってくるんですよ
その時は だからそれが善行為なんです
善行為を区別するのはすごい簡単ですよ
人間だから誰でもやっていることは
何であろうとも善行になりませんよ
誰でも生きている上でやっていることだからね
映画を見るはとか 音楽を聴くはとかね
夏休みはどこかに行くはとか
美味しいご飯どこかで行って食べるとかね
そういうのは誰でもやっていることで
ずっとどうやれば自分の会社がもっと広げるんでしょうかと考えるはとかね
それも結局は収入のことでしょうに
だからそういうのは当たり前
誰でも生きている上でやらなくちゃあかん
ごく普通なことです それに精一杯というと
もう人間失格なんですよ
そのために生まれたわけじゃないんです
そんなのは 食を探すことっていうのはとても簡単にやらなくちゃいけないんです
ちょっとだけ仕事をして
もう十分一ヶ月とかも食べられるんだぞと
収入はあるんだというぐらいの単純でなければ
もう人間とは失格なんですね
もう八時間じゃなくて
もう十二時間も仕事をするんだと
でも収入ではもうやっと合わせているだけですというならばね
そうすると寝る暇もなくなっちゃうでしょ
寝る暇も惜しんで仕事をする必要はないんですね
それは能力ないっていうことは明確なんですよ
で 政治家で見れば アメリカのブッシュ大統領には寝る時間がいっぱいある
きちんとあの人は寝るみたいですね
もう九時か十時になってくると朝まで
それで毎日ジョギングもする
それで自分がもうばっかでっかい
恐ろしい金持ちだからね
自分のどこかでなんかすごい飛行機で行くランチなんとかあるでしょうに
そちらにも行ってふざけて遊んだりもするわ
で 大統領の仕事もすると
それに比べたら日本の方がアメリカよりは倍大きいんですかね
では 仲良くではなくて
何でしたっけ？小泉さんの顔を見てください
テレビで ものすごい疲れてるんですよ
もうまぶたがもう膨らんでるんです
寝てないんですよ 全くもう
もう欲で耐えていると思いますよ
あれぐらい苦労は なんだこれと
やっぱり私はすごい悪口を言うんだから才能がないんだと
才能さえあれば もうちゃんと寝られるはずですよと
ピシピシピシと仕事をやっちゃえば
これ ほんのちょっとのことやるためにも二年かかるんだからね
だからやっぱり人間っていうのはしっかりできてなくちゃいけないし
仕事ぐらいはね もうすごい早くやって終わって
そう決まって はい 食べるものと住むところは確保しましたと
それからそれで関係ないプラスアルファの行為をしなくちゃいけない
それが善行為なんですね
十分もう確保したんだからということで
それからこの商売でないこともしなくちゃいけない
そういうのは全部自分の善行為になる
それから生活の中でも怒らなくちゃいけないんではなくて
怒るべきところでは怒らないと
欲張る時けれど欲張らないと
嫉妬する しなくちゃいけないはめになったところで嫉妬しないと
そういう心の管理もすると
それ管理してないんだから能力は全部飛んじゃうんですよ
何かあったら簡単に嫉妬する
そういうだったら誰でも嫉妬するんでしょうとわかった時点で
じゃあ嫉妬しないことにチャレンジするそうと
すると脳が壊れませんよ
その場合は 怒っちゃうと怒りがずっと続くんだから
心の中で 能力は死にますよ
そんなこと言われると人なら怒るでしょうということで
怒らないと 自分が怒らないで自分の心はもう能力はどんどん開発していく
そういうことで 人間の次元というのは徳を積める次元なんですね
だから怠ってはあかんということは
このストーリーで言ってるんです
で 話はそこら辺終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます